a lot of people know how powerful
journaling can be to hear about all the
mental health benefits that it can have
and I very much encourage long-form
journaling but it takes a lot of time
and a lot of people see it only as an
emotional thing I Journal when I'm
confused or when I'm sad or when I'm
angry and that can be helpful and then
you have blood lists which essentially
are for very specific things this is
what I have to buy you know these are my
goals these are all these things so
bullet journaling kind of combines The
Best of Both Worlds where it helps you
organize your thoughts as bulleted lists
that's one component there's two parts
of the bullet Journal method the system
and the practice the system is how you
organize information and then the
practice is more about what you do with
what you write down writing things down
is only the beginning so you write down
the things that you experience so your
events the things that you don't want to
forget which are your notes and then
your tasks things that are actionable